the official trailer for the seventh
season left us all speechless hyped and
anxious for waiting July 16th however
well this trailer is most likely the
best game of Thrones trailer yet
released there are a few shots that left
quite a big amount of fans confused in
this video I'll provide you an
explanation on all those shots that you
might be confused about well for the
whole and detailed breakdown feel free
to check out my previous video let's
start with the first shot of a
nervous-looking census start walking
through the godswood of Winterfell that
many fans assumed is confirming the
death of Sansa a sense as walking we can
hear Littlefinger's narration he says
don't fight in the north or the south
fight every battle everywhere always in
your mind which he is most likely
telling to Sansa now as I've already
said Sansa seems to be very nervous
shocked surprised and terrified at the
same time while at one moment you can
also see a figure behind her which in my
opinion is Littlefinger
well trailer starts a little finger
trying to manipulate sense I it ends
with sense as quote when the snows fall
into white winds blow the lone wolf dies
but the pack survives manifest assume
that the lone wolf is sense of herself
and she will die in the hands of
Littlefinger through his manipulation
but that is definitely not the case
while many fans also assume that she is
talking about Benjen start being the
lone wolf who will die by rescuing
severely wounded Jon Snow by setting him
off on his horse it's most likely in
other case as well in my opinion Sansa
is talking about herself with that quote
but that is not for sharing her death
it's rather for sharing senses refusal
over Littlefinger's proposal to betray
Jon and will choose to be a part of the
pack and stick with her family which is
not surprising at all at least not to me
since in the season six finale sense I
said that only a fool would trust
Littlefinger meaning that she's aware
that Baelish does not love or care about
her but cares only about his ultimate
goals wealth trailer starts a little
finger speech to sense a throughout
which he will try to manipulate her it
ends with sensitizing the pack
additionally this sense as quote well in
my opinion with the final words peter
baelish will here according to my theory
there will be a wedding between sense
and Littlefinger
but it will be orchestrated by the stark
sisters in order to put an end to a man
that is responsible for destruction of
their house as well for all chaos that
the Seven Kingdoms has seen in the last
few decades
since I will manipulate over
Littlefinger and marry him and in the
moment appear joy in a moment when he
thinks that he managed to once again
manipulate the Starks or even put a
dagger down his throat but before she
makes a final cut since I'll make it
clear that it's all been orchestrated by
her and her sister with that quote about
the lone wolf and the pact if you would
like to hear more details about the
white wedding theory which will end with
little fingers death feel free to check
out the video regarding the topic name
just like already mentioned theory let
me know so highway that this census
quote is actually from the very first
novel of A Song of Ice and Fire
on which Game of Thrones series is based
in the first novel by the name a game of
Thrones Ned Stark says the squad two
argument talking about Wolf's in order
to persuade Arya in to stop fighting
with her sibling now let's move on
another shot that many fans
misinterpreted which is this Chateau
Barrington dari on building a flaming
sword beyond the wall in a fight against
the undead army there have been many
comments on my previous video in which
many of you stated that beric Dondarrion
is azor Ahai barrack will obviously
build a flaming sword but he is not a
legendary hero that will defeat the
others and his sword is not light
bringer that will defeat the darkness of
the great other if you're wondering how
am I so sure well just like he did back
in the third season beric Dondarrion
will ignite his blade with fire by using
magic or more accurately a trick that
his good friend and companion Thoreau's
most likely taught him Torres became
famous for using a sword coated with
wildfire and set ablaze before combat as
a way of intimidating his enemies in the
fifth episode of the third season on the
road to in Chi Jorah had a conversation
with Barristan in which he mentioned the
siege of Pyke and Thoreau says flaming
sword Taurus was the first man followed
closely by Sir Jorah Mormont through the
bridge during the siege of Pyke stabbing
and terrifying the Ironborn with his
flaming sword it's also said that
despite his many victories Taurus earned
the enmity of blacksmith Toba Mott
because of his habit of dousing his
blades in wildfire which wrecked steel
beric Dondarrion is not new azor Ahai
and his sword is not light bringer anvil
Taurus use flaming sort of right in his
enemies and opponents Burke will use it
against knockings army that is contained
of a voice that are very susceptible to
fire let's move on the next shot this
shot of great warm heading into battle
is not confusing for anyone or
interpreted but is rather considered as
not very interesting shot but it should
not be as it is possibly confirming a
theory that I introduced you with in a
video regarding the first trailer long
story short Tyrion Lannister will most
likely be of the great importance Indian
solids invasion of Casterly Rock this
Lannister stronghold is one of the most
formidable and well defended castles in
all of Westeros but it won't matter
because Tyrion will show a secret
passage to a small group of the
unsullied led by their leader great worm
into Casterly Rock through the sewers of
the rock if you're wondering how
etherion know about the secret passage
to the sewers it's actually pretty
simple as I said in one of my previous
videos when Tyrion became a man at the
age of 16 he was given a charge of all
the sewers of Casterly Rock by his
father Tywin once-great Morman his small
team sneak into the lancer stronghold
they will open the gates for the
unsullied whereupon they will easily
defeat the Lancers forces and conquer
Casterly Rock let's move on another shot
that made many fans wondering about one
person's identity there's a shot in
which we see Ravens flying over a horde
of white sand one of them is being
washed by brain start - one with white
eyes however the leader of the undead
army at one point looks up and notices
the word raven weapon brain stopped
forging in the next shot we got to see
him in the wheelchair beside the
weirwood tree in the godswood
accompanied with one person while the
identity remains unknown
that person is maester wolkan that was
in service to house Bolton in the
dreadfort and later in Winterfell it was
unknown whether or not he still searched
at Winterfell now that it has been taken
back by how stark until the promotional
photos have been released and besides
featuring a huge meeting in Minter foul
it has also confirmed that maester
wolkan will continue serving at
Winterfell as we can see him attending
the meeting let me also say that it is
not surprising at all since masters have
politically neutral status and once
their Lord is defeated by his enemies
and possession of the castle officially
changes maester is expected to serve his
new lord the next shot did not confuse
anyone neither has been misinterpreted
as we can see this shot takes place in a
sea battle between Yara and Theon
supported the Denny's allied sand snakes
against Iran Roger and his armed fleet
however in this shot most of you surely
did not notice your gradual charging in
to fight against her uncle's forces
Valley
the other shot we can see her brother
Theon collapsing on a beach of
Dragonstone after he either escaped in
the heat of battle as they are
recommended him or was rescued by his
own man after defeat in the official
trailer we also get to see euron greyjoy
fighting and killing one soldier while
it's definitely going to be interesting
to see him victoriously arriving and
parading with his prisoners Yara and
sand snakes through the streets of
King's Landing all the way to the Red
Keep and pledging his army and iron
fleet to Cersei which will be
accompanied with a marriage deal there's
also a shot that provides us the
long-haired male pulling out a sword in
a place that seems to be the dragon pit
while the box behind him is going
favored to leaked plot the dragon pit is
a huge structure in King's Landing that
he'll star garyun once used as a stable
for their dragons it was destroyed
during the civil war of succession
between two rival branches of House
Targaryen fought hundred seventy years
before the events of Game of Thrones TV
series as a few remaining dragons die
out soon after the war it was never
rebuilt but left in ruins ever since now
let me tell you how it seems to be
fitting with the leaked plot there
stated that after the night Kings ambush
and Jon Snow end upon failing to capture
white in their first attempt Jon Snow me
later eventually with the nurses help
somehow managed to catch a white and
will bring it to the dragon pit the
nurse will then send an invitation to
Lords and important people of Westeros
as well as to Cersei Lannister herself
to witness the real danger in order to
unite their armies to stand a chance
against the night King and his undead
army once he attacks the Seven Kingdoms
there's also stated that Circe will
command the mountain to kill a white to
prove that they're not as dangerous as
John claims but the mountain will not
manage to do so because the whites
cannot be killed by the sword as they
can withstand stab wound and the removal
of limbs
even amputated limbs will still move
around on their own while decapitation
is ineffective as well as the headless
corpse will keep moving now beside all
leagues that already confirm that we are
going to see the dragon pit as well as a
huge meeting over there this shot from
the official trailer may have confirmed
that Jon Snow in the nares will organize
a meeting and bring a why to prove their
existence there's a high possibility
that the man that will prove to all
Lords and important people that White's
cannot be killed by a sword is going to
be the Hound since the hair and body
shape seems to fit perfectly with the
found
rather than the mountain if you would
like to know more about this huge
meeting in the dragon pit feel free to
check out my previous videos in which I
provided you more informations